i know from a lived experience is that
when you don't talk about an issue when
you don't talk about a health problem
all you do is you add a layer
to that problem or you justify the
embarrassment or you justify the fear of
not going to the surgery for for fear of
bumping into
into someone and then that leads to
more more more of a physical ailment or
again then maybe more of a mental health
problem by not addressing um by not
addressing this the issue and this
campaign ultimately is to break down you
know the barriers of fear and
embarrassment that we have and just like
the fireman said you know we live in a
fragmented world
and
where we we're fearful or embarrassed of
other people's reactions towards
our physical or our mental well-being
therefore you know we end up becoming
a worse society for not being able to
talk about it
and how much is it up to women do you
think gareth in order to speak to their
men folk whether it be their sons or
their brothers or their partners or
whatever because women are more
forthcoming aren't they they are more
willing to go and see the doctor if
there's an issue whether it's physical
or mental do they also have a
responsibility to look after their men's
health
i i feel there's a responsibility on
everyone but yeah i think women have to
play a part as well or just to ask the
questions you know i think sometimes
peop men
are afraid of raising a topic for say
the embarrassment they'll create an
environment where they feel they would
be judged or feel they would be would be
ridiculed whether that's by men or by
women so i feel everybody has a role to
play to create an environment where we
start talking about issues whether they
be mental issues or whether they be
physical um issues we start
conversations around it and you know we
all know when when groups of men are
together
um
then they don't always talk about things
that they should
be able to talk about for fear say of of
the embarrassment or or rejection but
some of my greatest friends are women
and um some of my greatest conversations
and some of my greatest kind of um
achievements have come from having
conversations um
with women as well so i feel like women
do have a big role to play in this as
well
so what's your top tip then for men who
are reluctant to talk
well i think what's great about this is
what what they've created is an online
doctor service so where where men are
fearful of talking or maybe fearful of
going to a clinic or fearful of walking
to hospital for bumping into somebody
they know there's a sense of anonymity
through online doctor.azda.com you can
go there and have a sense of anonymity
but also a sense of relief for being
able to start talk about your problem
and get one step further i know for me
you know even when i was diagnosed for
instance we're living with with with hiv
which is a great shame to me once i once
the doctors and i started engaging i
started listening to all the doctors
would tell me i didn't feel that shame
anymore i didn't feel like i had to have
that silence anymore because i had
nothing to be ashamed about so i had
nothing to be silent about